What is this? I'm impressed.
Good morning. I'm not Don Sadoway,
as you can tell. He's at a
conference. I'm not sure,
I think it's in Halifax. What the
heck can you have in Halifax?
Education, OK. A couple of
announcements,
the obvious, the first test is
Wednesday.
Maybe not so obvious,
but it's posted on the website.
There will be a review session for
those of you who care to come given
by myself in 26-100 tomorrow night
starting at 7 pm going until the
last question is answered.
That's why the infinity. Please
don't show up at 10:30 or 11:00 and
start asking questions.
I just flew in from Beijing.
For those of you who don't realize
it, it's now about 12:00 in the
evening tomorrow in Beijing.
Yeah, so anyway, I'll probably fall
asleep by about 10:30.
Anyway, OK, one little thing about
the quiz. Professor Sadoway always
gives some admonitions about how to
take these quizzes.
And, one thing I'd like to add to it,
and that is, and I told this to my
recitation sections that when you do
these quizzes,
in spite of the fact that it might
be trivial in some cases,
make sure you carry the units
through. If you've got a problem
that has units associated with it,
do the exercise of carrying the
units through because,
guess what? If the units are
supposed to come out in meters per
second and you get seconds per meter,
what do you figure the chances of
that problem being right are?
Zero, all right?
If the units come out in meters per
second, you will quickly discover
that the problems in 3.
91 are just not that complicated.
And so, even by units analysis, if
the units come out right,
you've got a good shot that unless
you've really,
really messed up,
that the answer is going to be right.
The second thing is ballpark it.
That is to say, guess the answer
ahead of time,
strip all the decimal places off.
Just go with powers of ten, and
then see what the answer should be.
And, you will be within 25 or 30%
every time. And,
that's a good thing to know because
if you come out with an answer
that's somewhere near the diameter
of the universe and it's supposed to
be the diameter of an atom,
then you will know that you probably
made a mistake.
So, those are two pieces of advice.
OK, last day, you talked about the
Born-Haber cycle,
and octet stability via electron
transfer. The Born-Haber cycle was
designed to allow us to calculate
the energetics of, in particular,
the ionic bond.
And, the thing we need to remember,
there are a couple things at least.
And that is that the lattice energy
as is depicted by the Madelung
constant is dominant.
And, the Madelung constant,
what does it represent? It's a
geometric factor that's unique for
each crystal structure.
So that's something you go and look
up. So, you go and look that up,
and those are the key things. And
as a result of that,
the achieving of octet stability via
electron transfer tumbled to the
idea of an ionic bond where one atom
donates an electron completely to
the other atom,
sort of like servanthood.
One donates yourself completely to
another.
OK, so that's where we are.
But we've got a few problems.
OK, sodium chloride works.
Magnesium chloride works.
Magnesium oxide works. All of
these from the group one and two
through the group five and six
elements, but what about elements,
what about molecules like hydrogen,
or nitrogen, or maybe oxygen? Or we
could keep on going:
chlorine, right?
We know these are stable.
And, if we wanted to try to fit,
say, hydrogen, into this scheme that
we have, we have to do what?
We'd have to figure out a way to
achieve octet stability by electron
transfer. Well,
we've got to hydrogen atoms here.
And, what would have to happen?
Well, we would have to have one of
these hydrogen atoms go to an H plus,
plus an electron, right?
**H --> H+ + e-**
So, now we have a hydrogen ion here.
But, at the same time, another
hydrogen would have to do that.
**H + e- --> H-** And, clearly,
we can't do both. This one here is
what? Hydrogen with an added
electron. That's isoelectronic
with helium.
This thing here,
this is just a naked proton.
So, it doesn't work. It doesn't
work. So, we need to find another
scheme, and that solution was
provided for us by G.
N. Lewis. And, he asked the
question, what if we could share --
-- electrons? And by now,
I mean the valence electrons.
What if we could share electrons?
Well, let's look at hydrogen see
what would happen.
Well, we know that hydrogen is 1s,
right? So, if we take another
hydrogen, we stick it over here,
1s, we know we have an electron here.
And, let's say the X denotes the
other electron from this hydrogen.
And now, we form a bond.
And what do we have? Well,
this is isoelectronic with helium,
right, and so is this, isoelectronic
with helium. And so,
each hydrogen has access to each
electron, and now we have a
satisfied system.
And we can do the same thing with,
well, we're going to do it with
nitrogen in a minute,
but this is a case where we have two
atoms sharing electrons.
And, in general, what we
have is sharing to --
-- sharing to achieve electron,
oh, octet stability. Let's look at
nitrogen to see if it applies there
as well. Well,
we know nitrogen has what?
Nitrogen is 1s2, 2s2, 2p3,
so, we've got five electrons here in
the valence shell.
If we take nitrogen,
we've got N2, and we've got one,
two, three, four, five.
One, two, three,
four, five, one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, right, one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight. Here we go. We've
got two cases where each one of
those things now is isoelectric with
neon. And, we have achieved octet
stability in the same way.
So, Lewis called this,
what did he call it? He called a
cooperative use of
valence electrons.
Right, so you take the co here,
and we take the valence here, and
out of that comes covalent.
And, let's be a little, now we need
to put a little terminology here.
This region in here contained the
bonding domains.
Right, and the non-bonding electrons
are non-bonding domains.
And this structure that I've
depicted here using the X's and O's
is called the Lewis structure.
Right, it's called the Lewis
structure. And,
let's see, this is actually from
Lewis' notes. Now,
remember, this is 1902.
So, there wasn't a whole lot going
on. There was a lot of physics
going on, but we didn't know a whole
lot about atomic structure back in
those days. But,
you can see, this is right out of
his notebook, and you can see he's
arranged the atoms by row.
And, he's trying to figure out,
see, lithium has one. Beryllium,
magnesium have two. Boron, aluminum
have three. And,
he's trying to figure out how to
arrange these things.
This is right out of his notebook.
And, look up at the top here. He's
got a bit of a mistake.
He's trying to make helium octet
stable. He's trying to put eight
electrons around helium,
and it isn't working.
But look down here.
He's got a box within a box.
This is 1902. This is reminiscent
of what? The shell structure which
people hadn't even thought of.
So, this is in his notes. He
didn't publish these notes.
And, he didn't publish anything
related to the Lewis structure until
about 1912 or 1913.
But, you can see that he was
thinking about this structure for
all along. Whoops, let's
see if I can get this.
OK, now, this is a more formal look
at that structure.
And you can see what he's done.
I don't know what the dates say,
1916, excuse me, and you can see
what he's done.
He's taken the elements,
and he's arranged them. And he's
stripped off all of the non-valence
electrons. And,
all he's done is leave the valence
electrons associated.
So, you can see the alkali metals
here: lithium,
one electron, and then beryllium,
magnesium, two electrons, all the
way over here to neon and argon
where you have stability.
There is fluorine and chlorine where
you have seven electrons.
So, that's his gift to us: the
Lewis structure,
and the idea that you could share
electrons and form a covalent bond.
Now, we need to go a little bit
further to put some more meat on
this thing because we haven't
quantified it.
We've got the concept,
but we haven't quantified it yet.
But, let's take a look and see
about water. These are so-called
homo-polar molecules.
The atoms are the same in each one.
And, let's try one with two
different atoms.
Let's take a look at water.
We know that hydrogen is 1s1,
and oxygen is 1s2, 2s2, 2p4, so,
there's six electrons in the valence
shell.
And, let's try oxygen.
Well, oxygen, we'll put a hydrogen
here, hydrogen here,
and one, two, three, four.
We've got to put six electrons
around it. So, let's put
one here, and one here.
We've got an electron from each of
the hydrogens.
So, let's put that here,
and that's there. And that works.
So now we have what? We have two,
well, let me draw this is as a
square. We have two bonding domains.
And, we have two non-bonding
domains. Now, we know that there's
more structure to this molecule.
Water is a very unique molecule.
It's one of the only compounds,
there's only I think three, where
the density actually goes down when
it freezes. Think about that.
Think of anything else with the
density goes down when it freezes,
and think about where we would be if
that wasn't the case.
Ponds would freeze from the bottom
up. That would be a bummer.
All the fish would freeze in the
wintertime. Water has some pretty
unique properties,
which we'll deal with a little bit
later. But, it all relates to the
bonding, all relates to the bonding.
And now, Lewis actually listed some
rules. And, what we want to do is
go by example here.
And these, by the way,
are called Lewis structures.
All right, and so,
he came up with a set of rules.
And, let's take an example, and see
how these apply.
And as an example,
let's take sulfuryl chloride,
SO2, make it a little complicated,
Cl2, right, so don't worry about
these compounds.
And, we'll tell you all you need to
know except for how to draw them.
And, it says, OK,
center the element with the lowest
average valence electron energy.
Well, if you look, sulfur is less
than chlorine,
which is less than oxygen.
So, sulfur has the lowest average
valence electron energy.
So, that says, put the sulfur in
the center. So,
put the sulfur in the center.
Then it says, count all the valence
electrons. Well, sulfur has six.
That's 3s2, 3p4.
Oxygen, two times oxygen,
that's 12 because sulfur is 2s2,
2p4, and chlorine, there's two of
those. That gives us 14,
and that's 3s2, 3p5, and so we've
got to come up with,
we have 32 electrons that we have to
use. OK, then it says draw a single
bond from each surrounding atom to
the central atom,
and subtract two valence electrons.
OK, and let's just put chlorine here,
chlorine here,
oxygen here, oxygen here.
So, two, four, six, eight,
minus eight, that gives us 24.
So, we have 24 electrons that we
have to come up with.
And then it says,
OK, distribute the remaining
electrons in pairs so that each atom
has eight. Place the non-bonding
pairs on peripheral atoms first,
which the higher average valence
electron energy.
All right, well,
oxygen has the highest valence
electron energy.
So, let's go and put the one,
two, three, four, five, six here.
Let's do one, two, three, four,
five, six here.
And, OK, and let's put the atoms
around. Now we'll do the chlorines.
Chlorines have seven. So, one, two,
three, four, five,
six, seven, right? One,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven. OK, so now we've got,
taken an electron from that sulfur,
put it here, an electron from that
sulfur, put it here.
So, how many have we got in the
sulfur? We've got one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven. Well, son of a gun, one,
two, three, four, five, six, sulfur,
one, two, three, four, five, six.
We've got six.
We've used all the electrons.
But what do we have here? Well,
this chlorine has taken one electron
from the sulfur.
But, the oxygen has taken two
electrons from the sulfur.
This is a kind of a special,
and you might expect that. Oxygen
has the highest average valence
electron energy.
So, it's going to want to scarf,
and take these electrons. This is
called a dative bond.
It's what it's called when an atom
takes both electrons in the bond.
So, what do we have?
We have one, two, we have four
bonding domains.
And, how many non-bonding?
Well, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, 11, 12. 12 non-bonding domains.
OK, so this is looking pretty good.
We now have octet stability. We've
got each. Each one has an inert
electronic structure.
But, a few things to note.
We know that because the sulfur and
the chlorine in the oxygen have
different average valence electron
energies, they'll have different
electron affinities.
So, this bond is going to be a
little bit different than this bond.
We have to account for that in some
way because we know that they don't
have identical average valence
electron energies. OK,
let's start over here.
OK, let's try another one.
Let's try something like four,
which is what? Methane. What do we
know about methane?
Well, we know it's stable.
But, we also know that it's
symmetric. Right,
it's symmetric. We know that it's
non-polar. All right,
so those are the things that we know
about it.
We also know that carbon is 1s2,
2s2, 2p2, and we know what hydrogen
is. And so, if we look at our box
notation, we've got three states in
the p orbital.
We've got one in the s orbital.
If we apply the Hund rule, we've
got up arrow, down arrow, right?
But, there is something else that we
know. We somehow have to take
hydrogen, attach it to carbon,
and we have to make it symmetric,
and we have to make it nonpolar.
And yet, we know that the shape of
the s orbital is spherical.
The shape of the p orbital is,
however, not spherical. It's
asymmetric. And,
moreover, they are at right angles
to one another that we've learned.
So, somehow we have to figure out a
way to take orbitals that are
non-symmetric,
and convert them into orbitals that
are symmetric.
Now, what does that mean?
If it's symmetric, that means that
each bond has exactly
the same energy.
Same bond, symmetric bonds means
equal energy, which means equal
links. If we can do that,
we'll end up with a symmetric
nonpolar molecule.
Well, this stumped people for
awhile until another fellow came
along: Linus Pauling.
He's famous for a lot of things,
one of which is covalent bonding.
And, he said, well, let
me take a look at this.
What if I were able to mix the
orbitals? All right,
what if I were able to mix these
orbitals and produce what he called
hybrid bonds? And,
how would he do that?
Well, this is where the thinking
comes in. He says let's just makes
the 2s and 2p orbitals.
And, I know I need to come up with
four symmetric equi-length bonds,
and let's just see, let's draw the
structure here.
And, if I take and I mix the 2s and
the 2p's, and by the Hund rule,
if I can come up with four, what
have I got?
I've got two states here,
three states here, two here,
I need four, and if I can come up
with these bonds,
four, by the Hund rule I'd fill them
like this. And there I have it.
I have four bonds that are of equal
energy, and he called
this an sp3 hybrid.
And now, I can't do the drawing
justice. But let's take a look at
how we do this.
The graph to the left,
this is the s orbital, symmetric.
These are the p orbitals. And,
these are what?
These are the probability densities,
right? Our friend Schršdinger told
us that if you solve for the wave
function, this is what the
probability densities look like.
If I now hybridize these,
if I take these and I make four
symmetric, now,
these are just the sp3 orbitals.
The hydrogen's not on there yet.
Notice, the orbital looks kind of
funny. It's got a big lobe and a
little lobe. And,
they are sort of backed into it.
So, this forms a tetrahedron, which
forms the sp3 hybrid orbitals.
Now, the hydrogen,
on the other hand, the hydrogen has
symmetric s orbitals,
and now if we take, and this is just
another way to look at it,
you take these sp3 hybridized
orbitals, and you add a hydrogen to
each one. And now,
what do you have? You have a
symmetric molecule, and let's see.
You have a molecule where we put the
carbon in the center,
and we go up like this,
like this, and out the back.
And now you have a tetrahedron with
equal length bonds.
And, it's going to be symmetric.
Now, will it be polar or nonpolar?
We are getting a little ahead of
ourselves. What makes something
polar versus nonpolar?
Well, if this bond has completely
identically equal sharing of
electrons, then this bond will be
nonpolar. However,
we're going to see that that's not
the case for hydrogen and carbon.
This bond will be nonpolar. So,
that means we've got one,
two, three, four nonpolar bonds in
here. And yet,
the molecule is symmetric and
nonpolar.
What's going on?
Well, what's going on is the carbon
is at the exact center of the
tetrahedron. So,
the nonpolar bonds cancel each other
out. The two sources of charge
cancel each other out.
And, you get a nonpolar molecule.
OK, so that's what Pauling did.
But, he did a little bit better.
Lewis, by the way, didn't get the
Nobel prize. But Pauling did get a
Nobel prize. So,
you say to yourself,
well, Lewis is the guy that came up
with the idea.
Why didn't he get the Nobel prize?
Well, he came up with the theory.
But he didn't reduce it to something
quantitative. Pauling did that.
And so, let's go back and take a
look at the energetics again.
Let's take another look at the
energetics. Now,
last day, we looked at the
energetics of the ionic bond,
right? And we wrote something that
looks, the energy is equal to minus
the Madelung constant times
Avogadro's number,
q1 q2 over 4 pi epsilon zero R zero.
**E =
-M*NAv*q1*q2/(4*pi*epsilon0*R0)**
And, we knew that if we know the
crystal structure we can get the
Madelung constant,
not a problem. And,
what we need to do is to get this.
Well, how do we get that? Well, if
we just take, for example,
MgO, and let's try Mg, magnesium
chloride just as an example.
We put the magnesium 2 plus here,
and then we put the oxygen here, O 2
minus, and we know that this gives
us our R zero,
right? So, we can go and measure
that. We haven't said much about
how to measure it,
but you can measure it.
If we wanted to get the chlorine,
we could just put the chlorine over
here, and we'd measure
another radius there.
And, we could easily calculate the
energies. Well,
with covalent bonding,
it's not so simple. It's not so
simple, and so let's see how,
let's take an example.
And let's take an example,
HF, hydrofluoric acid, all right?
Well, if we wanted to draw that, we
have HF, whoops --
It looks something like that.
But let's say we wanted to
calculate the energy.
Now, Pauling was trying to figure
out how to do this.
And he said, well, what if I were
to take, and just somehow add up
bonds, the energies of bonds,
or derive this energy from energies
that I do know?
And so, let's take HH,
the HH bond. More particularly,
the HH bond, right, and let's ask
what the energy of that is.
Well, we can look that up, and
that's table in your text,
by the way, B14 in your text.
And, we can come up with a number of
435 kilojoules per mole.
Well, if we want to get HF,
let's see what the FF bond is.
Well, you go look in your table and
you come up with 160 kJ per mole.
So, if I had to guess, what would
you guess the bond energy would be
in HF? Well, 435,
160, take 435, add it to 160,
divide by two.
Maybe that would be a guess.
Or, I could come up with some other
scheme. But, you would kind of
guess that it would be somewhere in
between. It would be somewhere in
between. Well,
what's the actual value?
Well, the HF bond energy is
actually 569 kJ per mole.
So, we have a problem.
The problem is we can't add these
two together. There's no way that
we can get from here,
to here, to here without knowing a
little bit more information.
And, we get that information by
going back to the definition.
What's the definition of the
covalent bond?
Sharing of electrons.
Well, they don't have to share
equally, do they?
And, if they don't share equally,
then the individual bonds might have
different energies.
And so, that's exactly what Pauling
proposed, right?
And he actually proposed sharing --
-- unequal sharing of electrons.
And, he needed to get quantitative.
And, he defined a term called the
electronegativity.
And, in your text,
it's E sub N. But,
in most chemistry texts,
it's also chi. That's the more
common term. And,
it represents the ability of an atom
to attract electrons in a bond,
all right? The ability of an atom
to attract electrons,
and in particular, in a covalent
bond.
All right, and he came up with a
scheme, and this is how he ranked
things. And, you can see a parallel.
If you take a look at the last day,
or the day before, you will see that
we talked about average valence
electron energy.
There is a striking parallel here
in that the group one elements have
a tendency to want to give up
electrons, whereas the fluorine,
chlorine, bromine, have a tendency
to attract electrons.
And so, this is a schematic of the
electronegativity scale.
Now, Pauling originally assumed
that fluorine was the most
electronegative element.
So, he assumed, he referenced or
normalized everything to fluorine.
Since that time,
we've been able to actually measure
these bond strengths by PES,
photoelectron spectroscopy. And,
when you do that, it turns out that
fluorine doesn't come out to exactly
four. And, this is a figure out of
your text. And,
you can see that fluorine,
instead of four, it's about 4.
9. But, it's as you would expect.
The most electronegative elements,
fluorine, chlorine, oxygen, are over
here. The highest one is neon.
But the lowest one is way down here,
cesium. I mean, you would expect
that the group one,
absent hydrogen, would be the ones
that would have the least.
Now, remember, the formation of the
ionic bonds was from group one and
group two, and over here with group
six and seven.
So, those are the ones that most
likely form ionic bonds.
OK, not only did he propose it.
He quantified it.
And, he did something even
better. Let's see --
He defined something called,
how much time do we have, partial
charge. Now, this is what got him
the Nobel prize.
And, he defined partial charge,
I'll give you the formula: G sub x,
this is in your text, N sub x --
-- in an XY bond, right?
Chi sub x plus chi sub y,
right, where G sub X is the group
number. N sub X is the number of
non-bonding electrons.
And, B sub X is the number of
bonding electrons.
OK, now let's take this and look at
what we get if we try HF.
All right, we know this is what it
comes out to. This is H.
We've got one "x" here. We know
that this is going to be,
by measurement, this is going to be
plus and this is going to be minus.
It's going to be a dipole.
This is plus; this is minus.
And, we know that chi of the
fluorine is 4.
9, and chi of the hydrogen is equal
to 2.30. OK, well,
if we plug that in, let me just do
one of them, just do the fluorine.
And, by the way, if you do this for
the hydrogen, it ought
to come out the same.
That's equal to seven minus six
minus two times 4.
9, or 4.19 plus 2.3.
And, that gives you a number for
the fluorine, minus 0.
9. Now, if you do the same for the
hydrogen, you'll come up
with the same number.
But, it will be plus,
all right? But, it will be plus.
And, so, what that tells us is HF
is polar. So,
we did that. And,
now let's go back to,
whoops, I'm running out of space.
Let's go back to methane and see
what happens there.
Let's go back to methane.
Well, the chi of the carbon is
equal to 2.54.
The chi of the hydrogen,
again, is what, 2.3. And,
so what this tells us, since these
aren't equal, that tells us that the
carbon-hydrogen bond is polar.
And so, if we go and we draw this
again, if this is the carbon here,
hydrogen, hydrogen, hydrogen,
hydrogen like this,
then this is going to be a little
bit plus.
And this end is going to be negative.
So, we know from our calculation
that we can do over here,
that this bond is polar.
This bond is polar,
but again, as I alluded to earlier,
because the carbon is centered in
the tetrahedron,
because of the sp3 hybridization,
the molecule itself is symmetric and
nonpolar. OK,
and for this, he got a Nobel in,
I think, 1954. OK, now one last
thing that he did is that he said,
OK, what's going on here?
Well, on the one hand,
we have ionic bonding where we have
complete sharing.
On the other hand,
if we have a perfect covalence bond,
we have identical equal sharing.
But we know that just by this
calculation, that we don't have
equal sharing.
So, somewhere in between,
the bonds are, we have a range of
bonds between ionic on the one hand,
and perfectly covalent on the other
hand. But, there's a whole
range in between.
So, what's going on there?
Well, Pauling also suggested that
for that case,
that the bonds are partially ionic
and partially covalent.
And, he came up with a relationship
to calculate the percent ionic
character. And, I'll
just give it to you.
This is a squared,
give you a percent.
All right, so this is a
relationship. And so,
you can see where chi comes in here.
And, this is the difference in
electronegativity between the two
elements, all right?
Let's see how much time.
OK, he also, let me see,
he also, lastly, to close us out,
he also developed an analytical
expression for the energy of that
covalent bond,
which is really what we want.
All right, so the type of bond
energies that we can go and look up
in tables are individual atom bonds,
H-H, F-F, and the like.
But he said the energy of an X-Y
bond is going to be equal
to the square root.
Right, so the X-X bond and the Y-Y
bond, we can look up those energies,
plus 96.3, delta chi squared, and
kilojoules per mole.
Where does the 96.3 come from?
Well, it's a conversion factor.
So, this gives you the energy of
the bond. Now,
if we plug in the numbers,
we plug in the numbers for HF.
What do we get? Well, we get
square root of 435 times 160 plus 96.
times chi H minus chi carbon,
whoops, squared, and you get this
number here is 2.3.
This is 4.19. You get the E of the
HF is equal to 608.
OK, now, where is my other one?
Somewhere here, 569 over here,
kilojoules per mole,
and by his formula he gets 608,
which isn't bad, which really isn't
bad at all. OK,
so what we've gone through today is
we've introduced covalent bonding,
and we've figured out a way to
quantify it.
Not only did we figure out a way to
describe how we quantify it,
but we've also quantified how we
tell the difference between covalent
and ionic, and percent ionic
character. So,
those are the key things to remember
for today. But hold on a minute.
What have we got? We've got a few
minutes here. I'm just going to
give you an example of sp3
hybridization.
There's a scientist,
Thomas Midgley, and Professor
Sadoway calls him sp3 Midgley.
He developed a whole lot of
compounds based on sp3 hybridization.
And, this one here,
some of you might recognize,
is dichlorodifluoromethane. It's
also known as a CFC.
And, this is the shape.
It's SP3 hybridized. Now,
it's not going to be symmetric is it,
because there's two fluorines and
two chlorines.
So, it's a nonsymmetric molecule.
But, what is so unusual about this?
Well, up until probably ten years
ago, this was the primary propellant
in just about every kind of spray
thing that we had,
hairspray, everything.
It's called freon. It's also used
in air conditioners.
What was neat about it is before
that time, the predominant species
to use for air conditioning or
refrigeration was ammonia.
And, not too many people, actually,
if you talk to your grandmother or
grandfather, there were some
refrigerators that were actually
made that used ammonia.
But, when they sprung a leak,
you had a problem. And so, by and
large, until this freon was invented
by Midgley, there wasn't a good gas
that had the right properties to be
used for a refrigerant.
And so, this was good as a
refrigerant. But,
something else can happen with these
things. And, I think you hear about
this in the news a lot.
If you get some of these in the
upper atmosphere,
a photon, an ultraviolet photon,
has the energy capable of breaking
this bond.
When it breaks this bond,
that chlorine atom, a free chlorine
atom comes down and reacts,
this is ozone, with the ozone in the
upper atmosphere.
And you end up with the destruction
of the ozone layer.
And, this is what you hear a lot
about in the news,
Kyoto, and all this kind of thing
about destruction of
the ozone layer.
Well, Mario Molina,
who was a faculty member here at MIT,
won a Nobel prize for describing
this process. He wasn't here at MIT
when he won the prize,
but here's the actual paper.
Now, you think you can make a
mistake on your exam,
take a look at this up here at tell
me what that all is.
I have no idea.
That's exactly the actual paper.
It actually should be chlorine
catalyzed shouldn't it?
But, who cares, he got the Nobel
prize. And, I'm sure he's not
worried about it at all.
OK, good luck on your tests,
and remember the review session if
you care.